سفاره الانذار تدوي ليلا في معظم انحاء
اوكرانيا وسجان بين موسكو والوكاله الذريه
حول امن محطه زاباروت
لجنه مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه للعلاقات
الخارجيه تدعو لمحاسبه النظام الايراني
وعدم السقوط عن قمعه للمحتاجين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشرته لاهم الانباء من
العربيه جنه المقاتلات الاسرائيليه فجر
اليوم غارات على مواقع الفصائل الفلسطينيه
في قطاع غزه قالت مصادر امنيه في حماس ان
اسرائيل نفذت خمسه عشره غار على القطاع
بينما اعلنت كتائب القسام انها تصدق
للمقاتلات الاسرائيليه بصواريخ ارض جو
وبمضاداتها الارضيه
للجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدفا نفاقا تحت
الارض في غزه قبل ذلك مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
غزه فيما اعترضت القبه الحديديه صاروخين
اطلقا من القطاع وفقا لبيان الجيش
الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
لا نستهلاف كتيبه 13
[موسيقى]
وفيما يتعلق بتطورات الضفه الغربيه اعربه
الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقها من التصايب
في الضفه وطالبت كافه الاطراف بخفض التوتر
والتعاون لتحسين الاوضاع الامنيه وقالت
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان هناك تحديات امنيه
شديده تواجه الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
مواصفات الدار ليلا في معظم الحال
اوكرانيا فيما افاده خبران وكاله الدوليه
لطاقه الذريه لوقعه انفجارات قويه بالقرب
من محطه سفاروجه لطاقه النوويه في
اوكرانيا
على الموقع الالكتروني للوكاله فان ثمانيه
انفجارات قويه هزت نوافذ المباني الاداريه
يوم امس ايضا
اعتبر تصريحات الوكاله الدوليه
تسلطات لروسيا في دوريات الجيش الاوكراني
باستهداف الاقليم بنحوي 300 صاروخ وقذيفه
مدفعيه خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه
معركه عسكريه مستعره وتصميم روسيه على
تحقيق اهدافها في الجانب الاخر من
المواجهه دعم غربي متواصل لاوكرانيا
التدفق للاسلحه الغربيه لا يتوقف لكنه لا
يكفي لترجيح كافتكييف في ميزان المعركه مع
موسكو
وفقا لخبراء عسكريين تمتلك القوات
الاوكرانيه معدات واليات عسكريه تتميز
بالتنوع والتطور الى جانب وفره في خزائن
سلاح مدعوم من الغرب لكنها تفتقر الى
انظمه صيانه وامداد تواكب هذا الدعم ما
يجعل هذه الترسانه دوما في وضعيه عدم
استغلال امثل لغياب القدره على تصنيع
الذخيره الخاصه بها
تشير التقارير العسكريه الى زياده في
عمليه التدريب للجنود الاوكرانيين من
الغرب مصحوبه بحملات تعبئه واسعه للمجندين
لكنها لا تتمتع بوجود قاده من ذوي الخبرات
التي لا يمكن الحصول عليها الا بمرور
الزمن والتجارب
ليست اوكرانيا وحدها التي تمتلك نقاط ضعف
روسيا تمر بمشكلات تتعلق بقدرته بعض
الاسلحه السوفيتيه الى جانب حشد وتجنيد
الافراد لكنها في الوقت ذاته تمتلك سلاحا
جويا وبحريا فائق القدره الى جانب فريق
انتاج وتصنيع واصلاح للمركبات العسكريه
وقد في الدبابات والمدفعيه ووفقا للخبراء
العسكريين فان ميزان التكافؤ بين روسيا
واوكرانيا يفتقر للتوازن حتى اللحظه
الحاليه لن تتمكن اوكرانيا من الانتقال من
حاله الدفاع العسكري الى الهجوم فما زالت
تعاني من خلل في اساسيات تكوين وحدات
هجوميه قادره على تحقيق نصر في عمليه
عسكريه قد يطول امتها
علي السمان العربيه
وهو في موقف اللافت قال الممثله الامين
العام للامم المتحده
ان قرار الغرب لتزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
لا يمثل خطوه نحو السلام ولا يصير في
الاتجاه الصحيح
ويناك
في كل مره يصل فيها سلاح جديد الى
اوكرانيا ما نريده هو السلام والعدل في
العالم وفقا لمثاق الامم المتحده والقانون
الدولي ما نراه الان لا يقودنا الى اي
اتجاه لكن في نفس الوقت لا يمنعنا من
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وبعد الانفراجات التي شهدتها طلباتك
للدبابات الالمانيه والامريكيه عين القوات
الاوكرانيه حاليا على مقاتلات الاف 16 في
مقترحت دوله اوروبيه ارسلتها
محرمه دوليا الى اوكرانيا لمساعدتها في
ساحه المعركه
الاوكرانيه
حيث تدور محادثات حول نقل طرف ثالث
لطائرات اف 16 اي اعاده بعض الدول تصدير
طائراتها الامريكيه الى اكياس للدفاع عن
مجالها
طلب وفقا لصحيفه
اف 16 او الصقر المقاتل طائره مقاتله
نفاثه احاديه المحرك خفيفه الوزن ومتعدده
المهام صممت مشاهدينا كطائره قنص خفيفه
وتطورت لمقاتله هجوميه دقيقه الاصابه
للاهداف ولديها طبعا قدره كبيره على
المناوره في الساحه تم انتاج حوالي
4,540 طائره اف 16 ولم تعد تشتريها القوات
الامريكيه لكن الانتاج مستمر لاغراض
التصدير مناقشات الاف 16 تتزامن مع اقتراح
دوله اوروبيه لم يكشف عن هويتها بعد ارسال
ذخائر عليها هذه الذخائر محرمه دوليا وفقا
معاهده امميه وقعتها معظم الدول الغربيه
استثناء روسيا كما هو معلوم فهي تنثر
مشاهدينا عددا كبيره من القنابل الصغيره
المتفجره وغالبا طبعا ما لتهديدا لفتره
طويله حتى بعد انتهاء النزاعات لكن الدوله
المجهوله حتى اللحظه تجادل بان القنابل
العنقضيه اسلحه مشروعه فاضرار هذه القنابل
الجلبيه جانبيه لم تعد كبيره كما في
السابق ويمكن التحكم بها بشكل كبير وفقا
تعبير هذه الدوله المجهوله وللمفارقه بان
شحنه القنابل العنقضيه هي الاخرى بحاجه
لضوء اخضر الماني لمشارتها في الانتاج كما
حصل مع دبابات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تتابع ولا ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
الجيش الامريكي يقتل قياديا في داعش وعشره
اخرين في عمليه انزال في صومال
اهلا بكم من جديد اكيد رئيس لجنه مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي للعلاقات الخارجيه انا
الولايات المتحده بحاجه الى اثاره قضيه
قمع النظام الايراني للمحتاجين في كل
المنتديات الدوليه كما فعلت في مجلس الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان
وطالبات
على النظام الايراني
مجربه اشار كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكيه سيناتور جيمريج عبر تغريده على
موقع تويتر الا انه بعد مقتل مقتل ميني
احتج الايرانيون على وحشيه النظام واظهروا
رغبتهم في المزيد من السلام والحريه في
ايران
للمساعده في نهائي اضطهاد النظام الايراني
وفي ايران اضرب محتجون النار في احد مقرات
البسيج في الاحواز كما احرقوا صوره لقاسم
سليماني في كاشمر في خرسانه
[موسيقى]
تجتمعوا مجموعه واسعه من الشخصيات
وكبار
مختلف الدول العربيه
واستمرارها لاكثر من اربعه اشهر وافاق
حدوث تغييرات جوهريه في ايران
ويناقشه المشاركون في المؤتمر وهو الاول
نوعه السياسه الاوروبيه تجاه ايران وضروره
ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني على قائمه
الارهاب
المسؤوله في المركز القومي للامن الايراني
او سبراني الملحق بجهاز الاستخبارات
والامن البريطاني حذر من ان قرصنه او
قراصنه معلوماتيين ايرانيين وروس يهاجمون
بلا هوانا صحفيين وشخصيات سياسيه بريطانيه
ومؤسسات من اجل سرقه البيانات وتعريض
الانظمه الحساسه للخطر
خلال اجتماعه مع رئيسه الحكومه نجلاء
رمضان بودن الاداره المحليه الى التزامي
الحياه الكامل في الدور الثاني للانتخابات
التشريعيه يوم الاحد المقبل متهم
المسؤولينا بلديين بالخروج عن ضوابط
الحياه
ربطه المعارضه التركيه ترشح الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان لولايه الرئاسيه الثالثه
بموافقه البرلمان وفقا لمقتضيات الدستور
كما اكدت المعارضه انها لا تزال تتشاور
الاختياري مرشحها للرئاسه
امام قصر العدل في بيروت التجمع اهالي
ضحايا انفجار الرابع من اب ومناصرين
لقضيتهم اعتراض على قرارات النائب العام
التمييزي غسان عويدات
جميع الموقوفين في القضيه واقتحم
المتظاهرون اسوار وزاره العدل وتعرض فيه
النواب المتضامنين مع الاهالي الى
الاعتداء في مكتبي وزير العدل
مشهد ماساوي ظل لقصر عدلي بيروت عكس الدرك
الذي وصلت اليه ازمه لبنان على مختلف
السعودي والتي طاولت العدل واسيسه
ما جرى امام هذا الصرح
قضائي بين المحقق العدلي في قضيه انفجار
المرفا طارق البيطار ومدعي عام التمييز
غسان عويدات على خلفيات اطلاق الاخير
صراحه جميع الموقوفين
على الملف العدلي اللي هو ملك بالنهايه
صادر عن المحقق العدل اليوم ما انه
موقوفين باشاره من النيابه العامه لا يصير
تاركم بالطريقه كيان المفترض يتم اخلاء
سبيلهم عن طريق النيابه عن طريق اليوم تم
الاستلام على صلاحيه رغم انه قرارات
القادم هي قرارات نافذ غير قابل الثانيه
وتحول المشهد الى هرج ومرج وتدافع بعد
تعرض عدد من نواب البرلمان الذين حضروا
تضامنا للمضايقات والتهجم من قبل مرافقه
وزير العدل
بلد ما بيقوم ما ممكن يظبط اصل ما في فاصل
السلطات واذا ما بيوقف التدخل السياسي
بالقضاء هذا اللي حاولنا له اليوم واننيه
حولنا نقول له لوزير العدل هو وزير وصايه
وعنده صلاحيات لما بيشوفوا خروقات كثير
كبيره بالقضاء يقدر يتصرف طبعا
الميليشيا اللي بتحمي وزير العدل
اتصرفت مع انه بطريقه اقل ما يقال فيها
وحشيه مطلب الرئيس انه ما نعرف شو صار
المطلب الرئيس انه هالناس اللي كانوا
قاعدين بشغلهم من بيتهم قتلهم ببيوتهم بدم
بارد وهلا عم يقضوا على عيال لونه وعلى
اهلهم وعلى القضيه ويزيحوا همم القاضي
بيطار على جنب نحن
موجودين وهذه ما رح
تمروارات
اقتحام من نفذها المعتصمون باتجاه قصر
العدل لم ينعقد مجلس القضاء الاعلى بحجه
رفضه ضغط الشارع وتدخل النواب سقوط مدون
سجل لدور القضائي في لبنان بما يعنيه من
ارساء العدل والعداله وهيبتهما او بما
يمثله من عمود اساسيين من اعمده حول ما
يطفي صوره قاتمه على مال الامور في القادم
من الايام رينادويه العربيه بيروت
في البيت الابيض ان العمليه الخاصه في
صومال التي امر بها الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ادت الى مقتل القيادي في داعش بلال
السوداني و10 عناصر اخرين من التنظيم على
جبال كالمسكات شماليه الصومال واستهدفه
الغاره الجويه
رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيه ابي احمد زياره
ثانيه للخرطوم استغرقت ساعات ناقش خلالها
عددا من البواضيع الخلافيه مع المسؤولين
السودانيين بينها سد النهضه والحدود
الى الخرطوم يقوده رئيس الوزراء باحمد
الرجل الذي جاء مبتسما وحاملا عددا من
الملفات في حقيبته قضى يوما طويلا مليئا
بلقاءات والمباحثات شحيحه في المقترحات
صافره البدايه كانت مع رئيس مجلس السياده
الذي اكد اتفاقهما على كافه القضايا
المتعلقه بسد النهضه وان يحتكم الطرفان
الى الوثائق فيما يتعلق بموضوع الحدود
مكتتما حديثه بثناء معهود على علاقات
البلدين
اي اختلاف او اي خلاف في اي من امورنا وهي
كلها نريدها ان تصب في مصلحه الشعبين
لتقويه هذه العلاقه بين الدولتين الجارتين
الشقيقتين
بعيدا عن الخلافات الخارجيه قريبا الى
المشاكل الداخليه لقاءات المطوله اجراها
ابي احمد مع الكتل والقوه السياسيه بمختلف
اتجاهتها لقاءات تستهدف الاستماع اكثر من
تقديم حلول جديده
المشكله هي الطريقه التي تمت بها همم
تشكيل الوضع الانتقالي همم وتحويل هذا
الوضع الى صراع الى صراع للاحزاب على
السلطه الانتقاليه
تتزامن محاولات ابي احمد لاحداث توافق بين
الاطراف السودانيه مع مساء تقودها القاهره
بين القوى السياسيه والتي من المقرر ان
يغادر معظمها الى مصر نهايه الشهر الجاري
يبدو واضحا ان مسعى كل دوله يسير في اتجاه
مختلف
من اشكال التنافس المصري الاثيوبي على
الاراضي السودانيه ومحاوله كل طرف من
الاطراف بان تكون له اليد الطول في حل
الازمه السودانيه
ابي احمد استمرت ساعات فهل تستتكمل
اللقاءات التي جرت في الخرطوف اديس ابابا
لاحداث توافق القريب ام انها ستنتقل الى
القاهره لاحداث اختراق جديد لن يعقوب
العربيه الخرطوم
من قبل سلطات الانديه في الولايات المتحده
عن يكون ماري وهي فتاهتنا امريكيه تبلغ من
العمر 19 عاما
بقتل طالب سعوديه المبتعث الوليد الغريبي
ذو الخمسه والعشرين عاما حيث تشير
المعلومات الى ان المتهمته استاجرت شقه
قبل فتره وجيزه في نفس المبنى الذي يقتله
الضحيه وطلبت من الطالب
من الاثاث لشقتها
يوم الاثنين الماضي كان هذا المنزل مسرحا
لعمليه قتل رحب حياتها الطالب السعودي
وليد الغريبي لل 25 عاما قتلته نيكول ميري
الامريكيه ذي 19 عاما تفاصيل الحادث
ترويها لنا صاحبه المنزل التي وجدت وليد
غارقا في دماؤه في الطابق الثالث تحديدا
في الحمام صاحبه المنزل تم استدعائها على
عجل من قبل القاتلين الاخرين للمنزل قالوا
لها بانهم يسمعون صوت لبدات مخنوقه لا
يعرفون مصدرها وصلت صاحبه المنزل على عجل
وجدت نيكول ميري تنظف بطريقه غريبه تشاجرت
هي واياها وعلى الفور لكل ميري تركت
المنزل
دخلت الى سيارتها واقلعت
هنا صاحبه المنزل
حاولت ان تطلع على ماذا لا يحصل تحديدا في
الطابق الثالث وجدت باب الحمام مقفولا
حاولت بكل الطرق ان تفتحه وفي النهايه
نجحت
لتجديد غارقا في دماؤه في هذا الحمام
يصارع ويلفض نفس انفاسه الاخيره حاولت
الاتصال بالشرطه وبعد 10 دقائق تحديدا
وصلت الشرطه لتعلن وفاه وليد عند الساعه
11:00
صباحا 51 دقيقه
تحتل وترتيب الدوليه الاول من حيث معدلات
سوء التغذيه التي سجلت ارتفاعات قياسيه في
الفتره الاخيره جرار سوق الاحوال الجويه
وقرارات طالبان
[موسيقى]
مقره المنظمات الانسانيه في افغانستان
ولكن بقراراتها مثل منع المراه الافغانيه
من العمل ففي اواخر 2022 قررت القياده في
النهار منع الافغانيات من العمل في
المنظمات الانسانيه التي كانت توظف النساء
في مد يد العون الى نساء اخرىات يعيشنا
وضعيه ماساويه في مجتمع محافظ يحرم
الاختلاط
المنظمات ارادت اقناع الحركه بالتراجع عن
قراراتها
فقامت بتجميد انشطتها تجميد تزامنا للاسف
مع انخفاض قياسي في درجات الحراره الى 34
مئويه تحت الصفر
التضخم وارتفاع اسعار وقود التدفئه
الجنونيه في بلد يعيش على المساعدات ادى
الى تسجيل اكثر من 160 قتيلا نصفهم ماتوا
تجمدا في الاسبوع الماضي
الانساني لتصعد بنسب سوء التغذيه في هذا
البلد الفقير الى المستويات قياسيه حيث
ارتفعت نسبه الافغان المعرضين للمجاعه بس
57% اي ما يفوقوا 25 مليون شخص العربيه
[موسيقى]
في الخطاب هذا تفكيرهم في ابراج العالم
قرات اسرائيليه على قطاع غزه بعد اطلاق
صواريخ من القطاع باتجاه عسقلان ومستوطنات
حدودي
لجنه مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي للعلاقات
الخارج
لجنه مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه تدعو لمحاسبه
النظام الايراني وعدم سقوط عن قمعه
للمحتاجين
نهايه هذه النشره دائما المزيد على
العربيه دوت نت شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]